Je suis surtout connu pour les vols à propulsion humaine,
mais ça n'est qu'une partie de ce qui m'a amené
à mon domaine de travail actuel.
Quand j'étais petit, j'étais très intéressé par les modèles réduits,
les ornithoptères, les autogyres, les hélicoptères, les planeurs, les avions,
des modèles d'intérieur, des modèles d'extérieur -- tout,
je trouvais ça très amusant,
et je me demandais pourquoi d'autres gens ne partageaient pas le même enthousiasme.
Ensuite, j'ai suivi l'entraînement de pilote de la Navy, et, après l'université,
j'ai volé sur planeurs, sur avions motorisés,
et je considérais le planeur comme un passe-temps et un amusement,
mais j'ai croisé de grands professeurs, des modèles,
qui m'ont convaincu, ainsi que tout le monde dans ce domaine,
que c'était une bonne manière de faire de la science complexe.
Dans le même temps, je travaillais sur la modification du climat,
tout en obtenant un PhD (doctorat) en aéronautique.
Le sujet de la modification artificielle du temps commençait à éclore,
et en tant qu'étudiant de troisième cycle,
j'assistais aux diverses conférences sur le sujet,
en faisant de l'auto-stop jusqu'à la côte Est,
et ainsi de suite, et tout le monde venait me parler,
mais tous les professionnels dans ce domaine se haïssaient entre eux,
et ils ne se parlaient pas. En conséquence de quoi,
j'ai eu une formation absolument unique dans ce domaine,
et j'ai lancé une compagnie, qui menait plus de recherches
sur les modifications artificielles du climat que quiconque,
et il y a plein de choses dont je n'ai pas le temps de vous parler.
Mais ensuite, j'ai lancé AeroVironment en 1971, sans employés --
ensuite un ou deux, trois,
et je cherchais à trouver des projets intéressants.
Nous avions AirDynanisis,
qui, comme moi, ne voulait pas travailler pour les sociétés aérospatiales
sur de grands projets de plusieurs années,
nous avons donc mené nos petits projets, et l'entreprise a lentement grandi.
Une chose excitante s'est produite en 1976,
je me suis soudainement intéressé aux avions à propulsion humaine
parce que j'avais prêté 100 000 $ à un ami,
et je m'étais porté garant auprès de la banque.
Il en avait besoin pour lancer son entreprise.
L'entreprise n'a pas marché, et il ne pouvait pas rembourser,
et j'étais le garant du prêt. J'avais dont 100 000 $ de dette,
et j'avais noté que le prix Kramer pour le vol à propulsion humaine,
qui existait depuis
17 ans à ce moment-là, était de 50 000 £,
ce qui, au taux d'échange, s'élevait à environ 100 000 $.
Donc je me suis soudainement intéressé au vol à propulsion humaine,
(Rires)
et je ne -- ma façon de procéder, d'abord,
réfléchir aux moyens de construire les avions,
c'était comme ce qu'ils faisaient en Angleterre, sans succès,
et j'ai abandonné. Je me suis dit, non, il n'y a pas de moyen simple et facile,
mais ensuite pendant des vacances, j'étudiais le vol des oiseaux,
juste pour m'amuser,
et vous pouvez regarder un oiseau s'élever en faisant des cercles,
et mesurer le temps, et estimer l'angle d'inclinaison,
et immédiatement trouver sa vitesse,
et le rayon de la rotation, et ainsi de suite,
ce que j'ai pu faire dans la voiture alors que nous partions en voyage,
(Rires)
avec mes trois jeunes fils, qui m'aidaient,
mais qui tournaient en ridicule toute la chose.
Mais ça a marqué le commencement d'une réflexion sur le vol des oiseaux,
et ensuite sur la façon dont les avions et les deltaplanes pouvaient voler,
ainsi que d'autres avions,
et l'idée du Gossamer Condor a rapidement émergé,
c'était si logique que quelqu'un aurait dû y penser plus tôt,
mais personne n'y avait pensé, et ça consistait à maintenir le poids en bas.
Il pesait seulement 32 kg, mais en l'agrandissant, comme un deltaplane,
avec trois fois plus d'envergure, trois fois plus de corde,
vous réduisez la vitesse d'un tiers, un tiers de la puissance,
et un bon cycliste peut générer cette énergie, et ça a marché,
et nous avons gagné le prix un an plus tard.
Beaucoup d'essais en vol, d'expériences, beaucoup de choses n'ont pas marché,
mais certaines ont marché, et l'avion continuait à s'améliorer, encore et toujours.
Nous avons trouvé un bon pilote, Brian Allen, pour le piloter,
et au final, nous avons réussi, mais malheureusement,
environ 65 000 $ avait été dépensés dans le projet.
(Rires)
Et il ne restait qu'à peu près 30 000 $ pour rembourser la dette.
Mais heureusement, Henry Kramer, qui avait créé le prix --
c'était un vol de 1,6 km -- a mis en place un nouveau prix
pour traverser la Manche, soit 34 km,
et il pensait que ça prendrait encore 18 ans pour que quelqu'un le remporte.
Nous avons compris que si on allégeait un peu le Gossamer Condor,
la puissance nécessaire au vol serait un peu réduite,
et si vous diminuez la puissance nécessaire, un peu,
le pilote peut voler bien plus longtemps.
Et Brian Allen a été capable, dans un vol miraculeux,
de traverser la Manche avec le Gossamer Albatross,
et nous avons remporté le prix de 100 000 £ (200 000 $),
et quand tous les frais ont été payés, la dette a été remboursée, et tout allait bien.
Il s'est avéré que donner les avions au musée
valait bien plus que la dette,
donc pendant cinq ou six ans, je n'avais qu'à payer un tiers de l'impôt sur le revenu.
Il y avait donc de bonnes raisons économiques pour le projet, mais --
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas -- le projet a été fait pour des raisons entièrement économiques,
et nous n'avons participé à aucun vol à propulsion humaine depuis.
(Rires)
Parce qu'il n'y a plus de prix à remporter.
Mais cela m'a amené à réfléchir à beaucoup de choses,
et immédiatement, nous avons commencé à faire des avions à énergie solaire
parce que nous avons senti que l'énergie solaire allait être très importante
pour le pays et pour le monde.
Nous ne voulions pas que le faible financement du gouvernement soit diminué,
ce que le gouvernement essayait de faire,
et nous avons pensé qu'un avion à énergie solaire n'aurait pas vraiment de sens,
mais on pouvait le faire, et ça ferait beaucoup de publicité pour l'énergie solaire
et peut-être que ça aiderait ce domaine.
Et ce projet a continué, et a réussi,
et nous avons ensuite mené d'autres projets en rapport avec l'aviation,
la mécanique, et les appareils au sol.
Mais dans le même temps,
en 1982, j'ai reçu un prix de la Fondation Lindbergh --
leur prix annuel --
et je devais préparer un papier sur le sujet,
qui recueillait toutes mes pensées diverses,
et mes divers intérêts dans ma vie.
C'était une chance unique pour moi de me concentrer sur ce que je voulais vraiment,
et sur ce qui était important. Et à ma surprise,
j'ai compris l'importance des questions écologiques,
ce à quoi Charles Lindbergh avait dédié la dernière moitié de sa vie,
et préparer ce papier m'a fait beaucoup de bien.
Je me demandais à l'époque, si j'étais un voyageur de l'espace,
et que je venais visiter la Terre tous les 5 000 ans,
au cours de quelques milliers de visites, j'aurais vu la même chose,
les petites différences sur Terre.
Mais lors d'un voyage à cet instant précis,
soudainement, je verrais d'énormes changements dans l'environnement,
dans la densité de population,
et c'est simplement inimaginable, la quantité de -- tout ce changement.
Je voulais -- l'un des plus grands changements est que, il y a 200 ans,
nous avons commencé à exploiter le charbon souterrain, ce qui pollue beaucoup,
et il y a 100 ans, nous avons commencé à exploiter l'essence souterraine,
ce qui pollue beaucoup, et la consommation d'essence -- ou la production,
atteindra sa limite dans environ dix ans, avant de diminuer,
et nous réfléchissons à l'avenir des moyens de transport.
Je voulais vous montrer la diapo --
cette diapo, je pense, est la plus importante que vous verrez, de toute votre vie,
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
parce qu'elle montre le rapport entre la nature et les humains, et s'étend de 1850 à 2050,
et l'an 2000 que vous voyez là,
et c'est la masse de tous les vertébrés terrestres et aériens.
Les humains et les rats musqués, les girafes, les oiseaux, etc...
la ligne rouge croît, ce sont les humains, le bétail, et les animaux domestiques.
La ligne verte décroît, c'est la nature sauvage.
Les humains, le bétail, et les animaux de compagnie, représentent désormais 98% de la masse mondiale
des vertébrés sur terre et dans les airs,
et vous ne savez pas de quoi le futur sera fait,
mais il ne fera pas diminuer ce pourcentage.
Il y a 10 000 ans, les humains, le bétail, et les animaux de compagnie
ne représentaient pas même un dixième de pourcent
et ne seraient même pas visibles sur une telle courbe,
à présent ils sont 98%, et je pense que cela montre la domination humaine sur la Terre.
Je donne une conférence à de remarquables lycéens chaque été,
et je leur demande, après qu'ils m'aient posé des questions --
à la fin de ma conférence, je pose des questions.
Quelle est la population de la Terre ?
Que deviendra la population de la Terre
quand vous aurez l'âge de vos parents ?
Ce à quoi ils n'avaient jamais vraiment pensé,
mais, désormais, ils y pensent.
Et ensuite, quelle population terrestre pourrait atteindre un équilibre
qui pourrait perdurer en 2050, 2100, 2150 ?
Et ils constituent de petits groupes, et ils débattent entre eux,
et quand je pars, deux heures plus tard,
la plupart d'entre eux disent 2 milliards de personnes,
et ils n'ont pas la moindre idée de la façon de décroître jusqu'à 2 milliards,
moi non plus, mais je pense qu'ils ont raison et que c'est un sérieux problème.
Rachel Carson y a réfléchi, et a publié « Printemps silencieux » il y a longtemps.
Le « Solar Manifesto » de Hermann Scheer, un allemand,
prétend que toute l'énergie sur Terre peut être dérivée, pour chaque pays,
de l'énergie solaire et de l'eau, et ainsi de suite,
vous n'avez pas besoin de creuser pour trouver ces éléments,
et nous pouvons être plus efficaces dans notre façon de faire.
Passons à la prochaine diapo.
Pour résumer simplement : « Pendant des milliards d'années,
sur une sphère unique, le hasard a peint une mince enveloppe de vie,
complexe et possible, merveilleuse et fragile.
Soudainement, nous, humains, une espèce arrivée il y a peu,
affranchis des contrôles et des équilibres inhérents à la nature,
nous avons grandi en population, en technologie, et en intelligence
jusqu'à une position de puissance terrifiante. Nous manions désormais le pinceau. »
Nous sommes au pouvoir. C'est effrayant.
Et je fais une peinture tous les 20 ou 25 ans. C'est la dernière en date,
(Rires)
elle montre la Terre dans une sorte de drapeau temporel, sur la droite
il y a des trilobites, des dinosaures, etc,
et au-dessus du triangle, nous arrivons à la civilisation, et à la télé,
aux embouteillages et ainsi de suite.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'il y aura après,
j'ai donc simplement symbolisé le futur par des blattes naturelles et robotisées,
comme une sorte de petit avertissement,
et deux semaines après avoir fait ce dessin,
nous avons en fait eu notre premier projet, contrat, à AeroVironment,
sur les blattes robotisées, ce qui m'effrayait beaucoup.
(Rires)
(Bruissement de papier)
Bien, ce sera tout pour les diapos.
Le temps passant, nous avons arrêté nos programmes environnementaux,
nous nous sommes concentrés davantage sur de très sérieux problèmes énergétiques
pour le futur, et nous avons fabriqué des produits pour la société,
et nous avons développé le prototype de voiture électrique qu'a fabriqué General Motors,
la EV1,
et nous avons obtenu du Air Resources Board les réglementations
qui promouvaient les voitures électriques, mais ils se sont ensuite retirés,
et nous avons fait beaucoup de choses, des petits drones, etc.
J'ai une vidéo sur l'Helios -- nous avons la première vidéo --
Narrateur : Avec une envergure d'aile de 75 mètres, cela la rend plus grande qu'un Boeing 747.
(Musique)
Le soin de son concepteur pour le détail et sa construction
rend la structure d'Helios souple et robuste
pour gérer les turbulences rencontrées dans l'atmosphère.
Cela lui permet de se promener aisément parmi les courants d'air
comme si elle glissait sur les vagues de l'océan.
Paul MacCready : Les ailes pouvaient se toucher au sommet sans se casser... c'est ce qu'on croit.
(Rires)
Narrateur : Et Helios commence maintenant à tourner son dos au soleil,
pour maximiser l'énergie de ses panneaux solaires.
(Musique)
Quand le ciel devient obscur, et que la température extérieure chute
en dessous de -73° Celsius,
le moment de son voyage où Helios rencontre l'environnement le plus hostile
s'est écoulé sans préavis,
si ce n'est qu'il est enregistré par des systèmes d'acquisition de données spécialement conçus,
ainsi que par leurs capteurs.
Approchant un pic d'altitude de 29 523 mètres,
à 16h12, Helios se tient au-dessus de 98% de l'atmosphère terrestre.
C'est 3 000 mètres de plus
que le précédent record mondial d'altitude détenu par le SR-71 Blackbird.
(Applaudissements)
PM : Cet avion a beaucoup d'usages, mais il est destiné à la communication,
et il peut voler si lentement qu'il pourra rester à 20 000 mètres d'altitude,
il pourra au final être en mesure de rester en l'air jour et nuit,
pendant six mois d'affilés, se comportant comme un satellite synchrone,
mais à seulement 16 km de la Terre.
Passons à la vidéo suivante, cela montre un autre aspect des possibilités.
Narrateur : Un tout petit avion, l'AV Pointer, est employé pour la surveillance,
grâce à une paire de jumelles orientables,
un exemple visionnaire de ce à quoi la miniaturisation peut mener
si l'opérateur est éloigné de l'engin.
Il est pratique à transporter, à assembler, et à lancer à la main.
Alimenté par pile, il est silencieux et rarement détecté.
Il renvoie des photos de haute résolution à l'opérateur.
Avec son GPS embarqué, il peut être dirigé de façon autonome,
et il est suffisamment solide pour atterrir seul sans dégât.
PM : Bien, et passons à la prochaine --
(Applaudissements)
Cet avion est largement répandu chez les militaires, maintenant, dans toutes leurs opérations.
Passons à la prochaine vidéo.
(Musique)
Alan Alda : Il l'a, il l'a, il l'a sur sa tête.
Nous allons terminer notre visite du cirque volant de Paul MacCready
en rendant visite à son fils, Tyler, qui, avec ses deux frères,
a aidé à construire le Gossamer Condor il y a 25 ans.
Tyler MacCready : Vous pouvez courir après, comme ça, pendant des heures.
AA : Quand ils se sont ennuyés avec le projet de leur père,
ils ont inventé leur propre avion extraordinaire.
TM :Et je peux le diriger en accompagnant une aile, ou l'autre.
AA : Ils l'appellent leur Planeur Promeneur.
(Musique)
Je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel.
Quel âge avais-tu quand tu as inventé ça ?
TM : Oh, 10, 11 ans -- (AA : Oh mon Dieu.)
TM : 12 ans, par là. (AA : C'est incroyable.)
PM: Et Tyler est ici pour vous montrer le Promeneur.
(Applaudissements)
TM : Très bien. Vous en avez tous deux dans vos sacs-cadeaux,
et l'une des premières choses --
le modèle de série semble piquer un peu du nez,
donc je vous suggère de plier un peu les extrémités des ailes
avant d'essayer de le faire voler.
Je vais vous montrer comment ça marche,
l'idée est qu'il plane sur l'air au-dessus de cotre corps, comme une mouette qui survole une falaise.
Quand l'air monte, il passe au-dessus de la falaise,
donc quand vous traversez l'air, il vous entoure, et passe au-dessus de vous.
Vous laissez donc le planeur en position dans ce courant ascendant.
Le lancement est la partie difficile, vous devez le tenir tout en haut, au-dessus de la tête,
et vous commencez à marcher en avant, vous le laissez aller, et vous pouvez le diriger comme ça.
(Rires)
Et puis aussi, comme on le dit dans la vidéo,
vous pouvez le faire tourner à gauche ou à droite
simplement en accompagnant une aile ou l'autre,
donc je peux le faire -- oops, ça devait être un virage à droite.
(Rires)
D'accord, celui-ci sera un virage à gauche.
Voilà.
(Applaudissements)
En tout cas --
Et voilà, donc vous pouvez le diriger, où vous voulez,
ça représente des heures de plaisir, et ceux-ci ne sont plus fabriqués,
donc vous avez de véritables pièces de collection.
(Rires)
Et ceci, nous voulions juste vous montrer --
si nous pouvons avoir la vidéo, oui,
un simple exemple de vidéo -- de petite vidéo-surveillance.
(Rires)
Il volait autour de nous pendant la fête hier soir, et --
et vous pouvez voir comment il peut simplement voler,
et vous pouvez espionner qui vous voulez.
(Rires)
Et c'est tout. J'allais apporter un avion,
mais je ne voulais blesser personne ici,
donc j'ai pensé que ça serait un petit peu plus gentil.
Voilà tout, oui, juste quelques inventions.
(Applaudissements)
Très bien.